(audience chatter)
- All right. Hi everyone.
Welcome. Welcome to Vegas.
Welcome to the session,
5:30. You guys must love us.
All right.
Today we're gonna take
you through this journey
of what's new with the Amazon EBS.
We're gonna cover the
innovations we have done
in the past 12 to 18 months
and we're gonna have a little bit fun.
So my name is Aaron Chen.
I'm a product manager at Amazon EBS.
Along with me is my
friend Sooraj Prasannan.
He's also a product manager at EBS.
We invite him down the stage
and I'll walk you through
the first half of the journey
and then we'll swap.
Cool.
So before we get started,
let's talk about EBS a little bit.
EBS stands for Elastic Block Store.
At its most basic,
it's a network attached persistent storage
to your EC2 instance.
The storage is connected
to your virtual machines
over the network,
so it's disaggregated
from your EC2 instance
in terms of the data lifecycle.
You're able to stop and
restart your instance.
You're able to reboot your instance,
your volume and your data
is still gonna be there.
That's why we're able to offer
the different volume types
because it's attached over the network.
You have your IO2 for
mission critical workloads.
You have your GP3 for
general purpose workloads.
EBS also provides the capability
of backing up your data
by snapshotting.
Snapshots is backed by Amazon S3
to provide high durability.
So in case of an issue,
you are able to start from your snapshot
and go back to your
production environment.
And the last part, between volumes
or between volumes and
snapshots, you wanna move data.
This can help you with
the different workloads
such as instant boot,
test and dev environment
creation or disaster recovery.
That's what we call data service.
So EBS consist of those three pillars.
One thing it's very important to know
is that EBS is not just
a provisioned disk,
it's just not only offering
the block storage volume,
but behind the scene it's
actually a vast distributed system
and it's maintained and
operated by our EBS engineers.
So it's with that kind of system,
we are able to offer you
different level of performance,
durability, and different features.
So in terms of workload,
EBS is a storage that
serves a variety of workload
all the way varies from a most
submission critical workloads
that's powering your ERP and
the CRM to all the boot volumes
that booting your EC2 instance
or to the indexing layer
and the caching for your
analytical reporting environments.
If you have ever spin up a EC2 instance
or ever run anything
on Amazon Web Service,
chance are you have used EBS.
So like all the Amazon services,
all the innovation we do
are deeply rooted in the
customer needs and use cases.
EBS is no exception.
So today we are looking
at the EBS innovations
through the lens of a customer.
Let's use this rapidly growing
FinTech company as a example.
They have their core business
as a operation database
for their real time
transactional processing.
They also have a analytical warehouse
so they can use that to understand
what's happening with their business
with daily and weekly
reports, generating insights,
trying to analyze their
business, et cetera.
Lastly, to provide the new features
and the new experience to their customers,
they need to build and test
and that's why they have
a developer environment.
So they're able to continually
bring more innovations
to their customers in a
more controlled environment.
So we're going to talk
about our innovations
in these three aspects.
Let's start with the
transactional processing systems.
So these are your most
mission critical applications
handling their incoming customer traffic.
For our FinTech customer here,
their customer experience
is directly correlated
to the performance that
underlying the system,
which is why their business is critical.
These applications
are typically backed by
relational databases,
and those relational databases
run on EC2 as your compute layer.
While the EBS as the
persistent storage layer,
these relational databases
yearly require a consistent
sub millisecond latency.
This is because that the application
will trigger multiple combined I/Os
and when they come together,
the storage requirement is
taking multiple transactions
or millions of transactions.
In addition, because they
wanted to rapidly grow
and expand globally,
they'll need the infrastructure
level parity worldwide,
that they can simplify
their infrastructure.
They're able to run their applications
without any modifications
with the same architecture everywhere.
It takes a lot of
operation burden off them.
Lastly, because of this system
is very mission critical.
The customer needs to constantly ensure
that their system is of high resiliency.
As a result, they need observability
to understand the
performance of their systems
if it's meeting their expectation
and they need to continue to test
if the system's resiliency is good enough
and if the failover mechanism
will operate as expected to
maintain the high availability.
So let's unpack all three, each of them.
Let's start with the performance metric,
which is the millions of transactions
or consistent sub millisecond latency.
So to deliver the desired experience
where a customer don't experience a lag
when they run something,
these applications require
to have a storage layer
that is a very low latency.
Imagine you are clicking a button,
you're submitting a form,
you are making a purchase.
These things yearly will
trigger a ton of correlated I/Os
that's either read or write
and all of us would hate
the spinning circles
and waiting for something to process.
So to ensure the customer
getting the instant response
on these things, each of the storage I/O
needs to have a very low
latency, ideally sub millisecond.
And to ensure that experience
is actually very consistent,
your storage layer
needs to deliver a sub millisecond latency
or very low latency in a
very consistent manner.
If you don't, they might lead to lag
or even the application unavailability
and then it could lead to loss
of sales or loss of revenue.
So there's also real monetary impact.
So that's why at EBS we recommend you
to run the very critical
workload on IO2 volume
IO2 volume provides the best
lowest P 99.9 I/O latency
among the major cloud providers,
and we further tightened
our latency guidance
from the sub millisecond average latency
to sub 500 microseconds.
Beyond that, we also added clarity
to how our IO2 outlier
latency differentiate
from our general purpose volumes.
So now customers able to
understand the difference
and making the right price
performance trade off.
So we cover the performance.
The next pillar is the
global infrastructure parity.
So as our FinTechs company grow
more into different places,
you also wanted to develop
in those new regions
that are different in the worldwide.
So you want the same
infrastructure available
across the regions.
It will reduce the operation burdens
and will bring the data closer
to you to their customers,
in this case so they can
achieve lower latency
and offer the same experience everywhere.
As a result, we expanded
IO2 block express volume
to all commercial and the GovCloud regions
meeting the customer needs.
So our FinTech company here
is able to serve their customer
in the same way everywhere.
Now we talk about the performance,
we talk about global parity.
The next pillar is high resiliency.
For application to be high resiliency.
It starts with one thing
and that's measurement.
A lot of time that we
hear customer asking us
these questions like,
"I have a EC2 EBS environment,
how do I monitor the performance?"
"Do I have enough headroom?"
We just got a issue.
Is it a application issue
or a infrastructure issue?
And the AWS can help.
So with this, you actually
want to provide observability
and observability have helped customers
to understand their performance
and to understand where
things can go wrong.
So over the past couple of years,
EBS has been on a journey
to improve the visibility
into the volume performance.
In 2024, we launched a metric
that is average latency in call watch.
This provides customer
to be able to understand where
the performance bottleneck.
This year we launched IOPS
and the throughput metrics in CloudWatch
so that the customer can monitor
and track performance trend and optimize.
These are the regular metrics.
We also launched another set of metrics
called exceed checks.
So last year we launched the
volume level exceed checks,
and this year we launched the
instance level exceed checks.
These exceed checks are
the zeros or ones metric
that if your driven IOPS or throughput
reach beyond your systems
entitlement, it'll turn into one.
And you know that's where
your bottleneck is, right?
With those signals.
It tells you right away that
the performance degradation
is because of the
entitlement of your system
or something else, right?
So with that, if you are
bottleneck is on the volume side,
you are able to use elastic volume
to tune up the performance
and to release that.
Or you can modify the instance size.
So now customers say,
"I can measure the impact. What's next?"
"I can see the average latency,
but how do I know that at what time
my system will get disrupted?
And if my standard operating
process procedure will work?"
So introducing chaos testing, right?
It's not a unfamiliar concept
because it is necessary
today to build a resilient
and reliable system by
proactively providing tests
and finding those vulnerabilities
and then you can fix them.
So chaos testing
is something that you've done
in a controlled environment
because you don't really want
to do it on your production.
So when you do that,
you intentionally simulate a
failure in this environment.
So you can uncover the hidden
weakness or dependencies.
And once you realize that,
you can fine tune the process
to improve the recovery times
and to test your standing
operating procedures
to ensure the system fell over
to the other side correctly.
And that is very critical
for the modern complex
and distributed systems.
So AWS fault injection systems or FIS,
force injection service or FSS,
is the service just for that.
It is managed service
that enable you to run
these fault injection
experiment on your workloads.
If you think about EBS fault,
it manifests itself as a
slow I/O or stock I/O yearly.
And in 2023, we've launched
a EBS action in FIS
called stock I/O.
So you are able to test
if a volume was stuck
and monitor if the timeouts
and alarm functions are
working as expected.
Well, this year we are
introducing more tests
in your latency.
So you are now allowed to
inject latency to your system.
And so think of it
as your simulating a grade failure, right?
So we offer four different
type of templates.
So you can run the test such
as the sustained latency,
increase in latency or intermittent
latency as like a spike.
And then your decreasing latency.
Of course, you can also specify
and build your own custom template
by inputting the read and write mix
and introducing latency to read or write.
So with the performance
tested and observed
with the impact on mitigated
on understanding operating procedure,
the other part of the
protection to achieve resiliency
is to prevent data loss.
Customers sometimes delete volumes,
by accident or even malicious intent.
And that is very important
because those kind of disruptions
can result in financial loss
or sometimes even damage
to your reputation.
So having such a data
protection strategy is critical
and ensuring the data can be restored
in the timely manner after
incidents is very important.
We've launched recycle
bin for EBS snapshots
a couple of years back,
and now this year we have
extended that support
to EBS volumes.
To use recycle bin, you are
able to set a retention period.
So when you delete volume,
your volume goes right to the bin.
Within the retention time,
you are able to perform a recovery action.
So the volume goes back to production.
Those recovered volume
is immediately available
and you be able to attach
it to your EC2 instance
and resume your workloads.
The volume will retain all the tags,
all the encryption status
or permissions that you
specified for it before.
For the volumes are not recovered.
And the the retention period lapsed,
then they are deleted permanently
when the retention period expires.
So you can create these retention
rules by a single volume
or by group volume, just
use tags and to figure out,
okay, now coming back
to our FinTech customer,
- [Audience Member 1] Is that
like the snapshot protection?
- I can't hear you clearly, I'm sorry.
- [Audience Member 1] Is that
like the snapshot protection?
(audience chatter)
- Yeah, it's the same thing
as the way lock for snapshot.
So coming back to our
FinTech customer here,
we covered the first pillar,
which is the real time transaction system.
Now let's welcome Sooraj back to stage
to talk to you through
about the other two.
- Thanks Aaron.
So Aaron spoke about the real
time transactional systems,
which are extremely important
to run your business, right?
But if you think about the
analytical warehouse system,
that's where you get to figure out,
"Hey, what's happening with the business?"
Where is the business going
and what do you do about it?
So it's extremely important in a way.
I think about it as
you have so many different
stakeholders in the business,
it aligns everyone on a
single source of truth, right?
So that's why your analytical
warehouses are so important.
And if you think about
some of the questions
you would ask from an analytical systems,
if you think about financial data,
it would be, "How are my margins trending?
How is my revenue trending?"
If you're thinking about sales question,
you would be thinking about,
"How are my products selling
in each of the different regions?"
If you are thinking about marketing,
hey, you're running different
kind of campaigns, right?
And you want to know how is the conversion
for some of these campaigns?
And if something is going
great, how do you double down?
If you are doing product development,
you're trying to figure out,
"How are my customers using
my product currently?"
What is the sentiment?
What are the complaints you're hearing?
So you can drive that to drive
better product decisions.
And on the inventory side,
you're trying to figure out,
"Hey, do I have the inventory
to support my customer?"
So there are different kind of questions
you wanna ask from the
analytical warehouse system,
as you would imagine,
it has a bunch of data which
streams into these systems,
and then you have to run analytics
and querying on it to get the insights.
So it's a very resource intensive system.
And we'll get into what kind
of product storage requirement
it drives and what we have done in 2025
to make the analytical warehouse system
much better to run on EBS.
So as I said, you have all kinds of data
streaming into the
analytical warehouse systems
and typically the storage is S3, right?
So you have your OLTP
systems streaming data
through your change
tracking into the systems,
you have your sales data,
finance data, marketing data,
IoT data, like think about
all the kinds of data
which is streaming into S3.
And for that data, you would think
it's going to be in all different
kinds of formats, right?
So if you have to run a query,
you have to normalize it to some extent
so you can run queries on it.
So that's where one place
where EBS comes into play
when you have to do the ETL
jobs on these huge data sets,
which is inside in S3,
because you need a
faster processing layer.
The other place where EBS comes into play
is when you're running queries.
It could be your nightly queries,
it could be add out queries,
it could be a nightly reporting jobs.
Customers need a fast storage layer there
to kind of speed up those queries, right?
So the first requirement is,
data has to be extracted quickly from S3
into the EBS layer.
So you can run the ETL jobs
or you can run your queries.
The second requirement is, if
you think about these queries,
if you're thinking about
aggregates and joints,
there's a lot of data,
intermediate data which gets generated,
which you necessarily don't
want to persist in S3, right?
It's a throwaway data,
which you don't want to keep long term,
but you want it absolutely
during the time when the query is running.
Because if you lose that
data or if the volume fails,
then you'll have to rerun
the whole query again, right?
So it's important that
EBS has enough capacity
to manage that query layer.
And lastly, if you guys are aware
of how these data processing layers work,
typically there is a spark framework.
So they take a query job
and they split it into smaller jobs.
That's one way to think about it.
And then you make sure that these jobs,
they split it into smaller sections
so they can run in parallel.
And also it's better failure management.
So if a small job fails,
you have another job which
comes up, spins up in its place,
another EBS volume attaches
and it goes, right?
And customers typically use
containerized environments
for that kind of processing.
So now if you take a step back,
we need high throughput,
we need large capacity.
Now you can definitely get that
by combining raid, different
kind of EBS volumes.
That's one way to do it.
But the hard part is in
containers environments,
RAIDO is not natively supported.
I mean, RAIDO in general is cumbersome,
but in containers, if you're
dealing with a lot of systems,
it's gonna be extremely hard
to support rating of volumes.
So that drives the requirement that,
"Hey, from a single data volume,
I need very high throughput and
very large capacity," right?
So that's what motivated
us to deliver GP3 volumes
with larger performance and larger size,
it reduces the need for
you to RAIDO volumes
in the container environment.
So we increased IOPS by 5X,
we went from 16K to 80K throughput,
doubled it from 1GB to 2GB throughput.
And we also increase the
size from 16 terabyte
to 64 terabytes.
So for example improvement in size.
So Aaron also spoke about the OLTP system.
So this also helps in
your OLTP environment.
So typically what customers do
is they have a production environment
which might be running on IO2 BX volumes
for latency consistency.
But then your testable environments
don't need that kind of performance.
So they will be running on GP3,
but they need the same size, right?
So if you have a 64 terabyte IO2 BX volume
before this launch, you would
be striping four GP3 volumes
to get that same test environment.
And it's very cumbersome
if you're snapshotting that environment.
So now with this launch,
you can have a 64 terabyte IO2 volume
and a 64 terabyte GP3 volume.
So simplifies your test of workflows.
So improves developer agility.
So that was one of the
features we launched
for the analytical
workflows also helps OLTP.
Now as you know, EBS is
network attach storage.
Just having a very large volume
with a lot of performance
investing just there is not
going to solve the problem.
You also need to make sure
that the network pipe,
which comes from the
compute to the EBS fleet,
is big enough
that customers can drive
that throughput, right?
Drive that performance to the volume.
And this has been a journey for us
because bigger the pipe, the lower the TCO
to the cost of ownership
of an EBS solution,
customers who have very
large scale of workloads
also helps them land like even
larger and larger workloads
on top of us.
So we started with a hundred IOPS
sharing with EC2
networking back in the day
with Nitro enabled,
all the Nitro instances
have a dedicated EBS pipe
with much larger performance.
In 2019, 2020,
we realized that customers
need a separate SKU
with very high networking performance.
So we launched R5b, also R5in,
so R5b had three X higher performance
than the generic instances
at that point in time.
Then we launch R6in to follow that up
and this year we launched R8gb.
It has 150 Gbps of bandwidth.
So that's 18.75 gigabytes of throughput
from a single instance to
the EBS fleet and 720K IOPS.
So with that, if you have an OLTP system,
as Aaron mentioned, they
are very latency sensitive,
they're very tightly coupled systems
to deliver that latency
sensitivity, right?
So that delivers,
that requires scale up
kind of compute, right?
If you think about it.
So a lot of CPU, a lot of memory
and as a result a lot of
storage performance needed
from a single instance.
So helps with that for sure.
You can land like even
larger and larger workloads
on AWS and on EBS.
The second thing, as I said,
in the previous slide,
these query jobs get broken
down into smaller jobs.
So when you're running
these analytical jobs,
you're using smaller instances
and generally when you
are using instances,
you don't want your CP or
memory to be stranded, right?
That's the most expensive
part of an instance.
So by making the pipe bigger,
we ensure that that doesn't
become the bottleneck, right?
So you have better TCO of
running an EBS solution.
So that was for the analytical
workflows helps OLTP as well.
We use that as an example
because it's easier to explain
in the analytical framework.
Now, the next thing, and the
last one we wanna discuss
is the developer environment, right?
So if you think about a
developer environment,
the customer has a production environment
which is taking live traffic,
they want test dev environments
for development purposes,
but the requirements are
the production environment
should not be impacted
when you're creating a test environment.
You also want to make sure
that the data you are transferring
to the test environment
is not sensitive, right?
You don't want that data
to be widely shared.
So those are two requirements
on the production system
when you're trying to create
a copy of your volume.
And then the other workflow
and the other requirement
on the test environment is,
they want the data to mimic
production environment
so there's this push
and pull from both sides
because you want similar rich data.
So you can work on that,
you can similar real
world examples, right?
So if you're a person
managing infrastructure
for developers,
there are a couple of things
you want to think about.
You wanna ensure that the test environment
is as close to the product
environment as possible.
And if you have a
distributed development team,
you want everybody to work
off the same code base, right?
So those are the two things.
So think about our FinTech customer.
They have a real time transaction system,
live traffic, there's an issue.
They want the ability to create
a copy of that environment
as quickly as possible, debug
the issue, root cause issue,
fix the issue, and deploy the fix, right?
So we'll see how we made
that the ER experience simpler this year,
but with the features we have launched.
So the digging deeper into
both of those workflows.
So the first workflow is a copy workflow.
So you have a production environment,
which with EC2 instances,
with a bunch of EBS volumes attached,
you create your test environment.
Again, instances with a lot
of volumes attached, right?
So in the prod environment,
you don't want any kind of impact
when you're creating these copy workflows,
you don't want to copy
sensitive data as well.
So that's a requirement on the prod side,
on the test dev side,
you want to create more
frequent copies of the data
so it's as fresh to the production
environment as it can be.
So you want to be very close to that.
The other requirement is
on the production side,
you might have volumes, you
might use IO2 BX volumes, right?
And on the test dev side,
you might not need IO2 BX
because it's not very latency sensitive.
Doesn't make sense to have I02 BX there.
So you might want the ability
to mix and match volume types.
Your source could be IO2,
your destination could be GP3.
So those are the requirements
which that workflow drives.
And then if you think about
the second workflow, which is,
"Hey, I want all my developers,"
like this FinTech company
which we're talking about
is growing globally, right?
So they have developers
all around the globe,
they wanna make sure
everybody's working
off the same code base.
So in that case, what customers
do is they create a AMI,
which is Amazon Machine
Image, a golden AMI,
which basically underneath the covers
is creating snapshots, right?
AMI creates snapshots and
then they copy that snap,
copy the AMI across different regions
and copying the AMI
triggers copy snapshots
underneath the covers.
And then when you create
a dev environment,
you are launching an
instance from an AMI, right?
So again, that's a volume
getting created from a snapshot.
So you can see there are
multiple moving parts here.
Customer triggers these workflow,
sometimes daily, sometimes weekly
based on that development cycle.
So for both of these workflows,
they require predictability and speed
because if it's not predictable and fast,
it's very cumbersome to manage, right?
So that's what we heard
consistently from our customers.
So let's look at each what
we did in each one of them.
So we launched EBS
volume clones this year.
So previously customers,
when they had to create a volume clone,
they would use snapshot as
a intermediate layer, right?
You would create, in FinTech environment,
they would've I02 BX volumes,
they would create a snapshot
of those IO2 BX volumes,
which means pushing data
from the EBS volume,
the EBS fleet to EBS
snapshots, which is on S3.
Then you're creating a
volume from that snapshot,
which means again, pulling down data
from the snapshot down
to the EBS volume, right?
So it takes time to do that.
It's cumbersome to do that.
And then after the data is fully,
like after the volume
is fully initialized,
you would attach those volumes
to your test dev environment
and and your instances to
trigger the test of workflows.
With volume clones, what we have done
is we have taken the
snapshot out of the picture.
So now you copy data directly
from the EBS source volume
to the target volume.
It's a single API call, right?
And you can create a performance volume
with a single API call instantly.
You can start with an IO2 BX
volume on the left hand side,
create a GP3 volume on the right hand side
for your test of environment.
And we make sure that the prod
environment, the prod data,
prod volume does not get any
kind of performance impact.
So those were the requirements
from the previous slide.
So you have done that.
So as I said, the previous
workflow used to be,
say you are a developer
managing the previous workflow,
you have to know when the
snapshot was completed.
You have to know when the
volume is fully initialized.
That's very cumbersome.
With this we have improved
developer efficiency
and if you recall, the other requirement
was to create copies more frequently.
Now that copies doesn't take
a lot of time to create.
You can create more copies frequently
to keep your test dev environment
as close as possible to
the production environment,
which improves the quality
of your code, right?
So that's what we did.
Other than this workflow we
also see customers use cloning.
And this was an emergent use case
I think we kind of knew could be used
for blue-green deployments.
So blue-green deployments
are where customers would
have two live environments.
There's blue environment, which
is the existing code base,
and they have a green environment,
which is the new code base.
And over a period of time
they start moving traffic over
and if everything goes
fine, they switch over
and the green environment
becomes the new environment
and if something goes wrong,
they can quickly flip back
to the blue environment.
So it reduces the risk when
you're deploying software
also makes it much more seamless.
So previously customers used
to use snapshots for that.
So you can imagine if
you're using Snapshot,
as I said, it takes more time.
So as a developer, you're
managing the blue and the green,
the deployments with green environments
for a much longer time, right?
Because you have both of those things
going at the same time.
Now with copy,
you can just have the
new environment created,
you still have to manage
the flip over and all that.
That's still on you,
but still is much easier and much simpler
to do than before, right?
So it minimizes you can switch,
minimizes the developer environment
and improves developer agility,
which was one of the main
motivations for doing this.
So that's volumes clones.
The other workflow was the golden image,
which you had and you want
it to copy it across regions
to developers all across the world, right?
And as I said, there are
multiple steps in that workflow.
One of the things you have
to do is you create an AMI,
then you copy the AMI
across different regions
and then you create volumes from it.
You don't want, like if a
developer is coming online
in the morning, you
don't want the developer
to deal with a system which is
not fully performing, right?
That's waste of their time
and waste of resources.
So that's one constant feedback we heard.
So copy AMI Workflow by design
is the best effort workflow.
So if you're copying an AMI
across different regions,
based on how busy the regions are,
your speeds will vary, right?
So a developer in dub region
would get something faster,
was a developer in Farah
region, for example,
EU West and US2.
I use the internal names.
So we launched time-based AMI
copy last year in February.
So you can give us a
time as low as 15 minutes
and we'll make sure
that across all regions
these AMIs get copied
in 15 minutes, right?
So that makes it much easier,
is predictable that the
AMIs are gonna be there.
The other part of the
workflow is creating,
launching an instance from an AMI.
And that triggers pulling
data from the snapshot
to the EBS volume, right?
So that workflow is also not predictable.
It's best effort based on EBS snapshot,
how heavy the load is on the snapshot,
on the S3 fleet and on
the EBS volume fleet.
So here again we launched provision RAIDO
for volume initial initialization,
you can go up to 300 megs.
We ensure that the data gets pulled down
from S3 at that speed, right?
So you know practically when the volume
will be fully ready and you
can give that to your developer
and he can be sure that the
volume is fully performed.
Along with that, we also
launched the ability to know
that hey, all the data from the snapshot
is fully pulled on from
into the EBS volume.
So we know that the volume is ready
to take production traffic.
That's available for all volume types,
not just in the context of this feature.
So volume initialization is
one of our basic workflows.
If you think about AMI launches, right?
It triggers the volume
initialization workflow.
And we have seen customers
who have a single AMI
launching hundreds of
instances use this feature
because it gives them predictability
that all those instances are ready
to take on workload production traffic.
We see customers who are
copying environments across AZs
because the copy volume is
an AZ copy of the volume.
If you're copying production
environments across AZs,
this is again useful to make
it predictable and fast.
And lastly, if you are
recovering from a disaster,
you are recovering from
a snapshot to a volume,
you have strict RTOs
recovery time objectives,
this ensures that you're able to meet
that recovery point objective.
So it's a core primitive for us
and we are gonna invest
in that to make it faster.
So that's it speeds up a lot of workflows.
Just summarizing all the
things we spoke about here.
So Adam spoke about the real
time transaction system,
extremely latency sensitive.
So we reduced the IO2 BX
volume latency definition
from sub millisecond to
sub 500 microseconds.
So you can handle even
stricter latency guidance.
We to make sure that all your customers
can benefit from this latency
we have IO2 worldwide available
so you can develop,
have the same same stack
across the whole whole world.
We launched metrics,
performance exceeded checks,
so volume exceeded checks
we launched last year
and instance exceeded check
we launched this year.
So in a stack it's very easy
to figure out if the
bottleneck is the instance
or is the volume.
We launched average
latency metrics last year,
average IOPS and throughput this year.
So you can trend your performance
over a period of time,
put in alarms and figure out
when something is going wrong.
On the resiliency side,
we talked about latency
injection with FIS,
fault injection simulator.
We had launched pausing I/O in 2023
that basically simulates,
hey, if you have timer in your stack,
how does it propagate
from the storage upwards?
If you have certain alarms,
how does that propagate?
In this year we launched the ability
to inject latency into
your data part, right?
And we have four templates,
but you can also create your own template
with redirect mixes
and how much microseconds of latency
you want on the read
part, on the write part.
And lastly, customers
accidentally delete data,
delete a volume, delete a snapshot.
We had recycled bin
production for snapshots.
We extended that to volumes as well.
On the analytical warehouse system,
you need a lot of speed
to pull data from S3
into the EBS fleet.
So we have larger and faster
single volume GP3 volumes,
RAGB with one 50 GBP as a bandwidth
and 720K IOPS, as I mentioned
also helps your OLTP systems
the larger and faster GP3
makes test dev environments
much more simpler to use
and the REGB enables you
to land even larger and larger
workloads on top of EBS.
And for dev environments,
for developer environment to
improve developer agility,
we launch volume clones.
We can create instantly
create a performance volume
from another EBS volume
in the same AZ provision
RAIDO for initialization
and time-based AMI copy
makes having a golden image
and copying it across the
globe much more easier,
initialization status helps you understand
when your volume is fully ready
and you can put that in production
to take on latency sensitive applications.
So that's the bunch of
features we launched this year.
These are the others EBS sessions
if you are interested in.
The last one is about
networking and EBS workloads,
if you like that and he'll
be there for that session.
So I can go for that one
and then Aaron and I
will be hanging out here.
So if you have any questions, let us know.
Please take the survey,
we read all the surveys.
If you can put notes
in there, that's great
'cause we look at that and figure out
how to make the session better next year.
But thanks for coming.
I know it's a very late session,
so we appreciate you all being here.
Thank you.